okay
the world outsides hanging on by a very
thin thread it's only a matter of time
before the flare virus wipes the rest of
us out his entire facility is designed
to keep you safe
were they taking her
they're hiding something these people
are not they say they are it's almost
what did you see
we never escaped it's wicked it's all
just been part of their playing maybe
they only have one question whose side
are you on
Thomas the maze is one thing but you
kids my last one day out in the scorch
something inside of us that wicked wants
so we can't let them find us
you guys don't have to come with me I
know we can make
no one's come out of the Scorch in a
long time
all those kids that were left behind I
don't want to end up like that
hello Thomas you know me
a lot of our friends died for us to get
this far
so we can't give up
this is about everyone Wicked's ever
taken don't ever stop so I'm gonna stop
them don't you want to know why this all
happened
you're so close to the truth
Hey